voyons comment on a réussi à créer un
effet viral dans les médias en 1835 avec
une nouvelle scientifique de vie sur la
lune
[Musique]
alors nous sommes allés paint 1835 du
côté de new york à une époque où les
journaux se vendent beaucoup et il ya
une forte compétition pour se hisser au
sommet des palmarès et c'est comme ça
que itunes adam's hoc qui travaille pour
le journal de saône par ce stratagème
afin de créer une fausse nouvelle virale
il va faire en sorte que les ventes de
son journal vont exploser
ils vont reprendre fait la théorie d'un
astronome qui s'appelle sur john
herschel donc il est vivant il existe le
publier cette théorie là qui avec ce
qu'on voit sur la lune les cratères les
formations les probablement possibilité
qu'il ya eu de la vie sur la lune ou qui
en est peut-être encore aujourd'hui
alors on va récupérer cette théorie
scientifique là et on va annoncer le 21
au 1835 une série de six articles qui
vont changer complètement notre
perception de la lune et de la vie sur
la lune et donc ne serait-ce que
l'annoncent vos créé un engouement les
gens vont vouloir acheter deux semaines
pour savoir qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé sur
la lune et c'est comme ça qu'on va
arriver avec une photographie une
gravure en fait qui va illustrer un peu
cette vie assez spectaculaire sur la
lune on va parler de bison de castor qui
n'ont pas de cuve on voit aussi parler
d'hommes et de femmes qui habitent sur
la lune qui ont été aperçus et qui
possible des ailes de chauve souris
alors la stratégie fonctionne les
tirages de saône explose
du côté de new york qui ont réussi en
fait avait laissé planer la fausse
nouvelle pendant près de cinq ans en
fait le l'astronome en question qui est
derrière la nouvelle sur john russell au
départ c'est du bois c'est ici rigolons
j'en ferais pas un plat mais va
commencer à et hérité lorsqu'il vous
réalisez que les gens croient vraiment à
cette théorie là et c'est ce qui
explique qu'en 1840 220 obligé de se
rétracter et d'expliquer
stratagème et pourtant ça n'aura aucun
impact puisque deux sommes vraiment ce
lycée pendant plusieurs décennies au
sommet des ventes de new york
[Musique]